hello there another season ends and
another recap is here for you if you
can't quite remember what happened over
the last 11 weeks of fortnite this time
it's all about chapter three season four
Paradise if this helps please think
about using Code adamarial it would
really help anyway you ready let's do
this
[Music]
then we need to jump back
two to Nation led us into war with the
imagined order as we raced against time
to take out the collider before all life
was wiped off the island long story
short we did it thanks to the
reassembled Mech and the paradigm's
return to the seven the zero point was
finally free The Following season that
zero point there fell dormant as we did
absolutely nothing for a season all the
while watched by a mysterious figure the
reality tree's roots spread constantly
until season four began Welcome To
Paradise
[Music]
week one the season begins with a
revelation in yet another secret bunker
underground the origin the visitor the
scientist and the Paradigm are
investigating a mysterious Chrome
substance that is multiplying moments
later it consumes three of them leaving
the Paradigm the last survivor it is
revealed The Herald is taking over the
island thanks to that metallic goo
Paradigm escapes by recalibrating the
0.2 her Homeworld reality 659 and that
was the last we saw of her the herald
then chose to build her new Palace on
the ruins of sanctuary and did this for
the next 11 weeks only stopping to
eliminate pesky lupus from time to time
the first POI to be claimed by The
Herald was the old volcano every
building consumed yet the pirate ship
known as the Driftwood found a way to
get off the ground to save itself this
was also the solution of no sweat
Insurance in tilted Towers who
systematically saved pois all seasoned
with balloons things were getting out of
hand and we needed a hero
week two over the first 14 days we began
a new quest line alongside Jonesy and
the scientists slightly erratic AI Amy
computer
tree human kick rocks we visited the
reality tree Once a tree of life now a
husk of its former self and somehow we
figured out that the roots of the tree
were being used by the Paradigm to
communicate with us after running
errands to complete the scientists
research we finally were able to hear
the transmission
hear me
Christmas in short and I'll send
everything I know keep safe and listen
there will be no
sense here
typically it cut off the rest of the
mission saw Jones and Amy get over their
differences and agree to save the island
I'm sorry for calling you a toaster Amy
I just want to see the scientist again
oh and it was also fortnite battle
royale's fifth birthday this week so
cake
a huge curveball was thrown away in week
three by playing as the battle pass skin
bites we could interact with certain
Chrome TVs
we see you're finally prepared to face
your fate
But first you must prove yourself
bite was recruited by the nothing the
promise of gifts kept him coming back
for more slowly losing himself let's
check back on him in a few weeks
elsewhere sleepy sound was consumed by
the Chrome but luckily no sweat
Insurance saved many buildings most
importantly the lighthouse strangely a
few new pois had appeared first the
original loot lake house from chapter
one and then this Mansion two weeks
later it seemed to be far the Halloween
update the greatest update in the Side
Story of the Bromance happened this week
Sylvania the 7th century was watching
The Lads and now she's one of them from
humble beginnings The Misfits are now
five strong damn it I love those guys
week five was the long-awaited Halloween
update a new Mythic item joined the game
and was quickly removed by epic games
fortnite is gray elsewhere the legend
that is Ash and the Evil Dead arrived
with the iconic cabin found in the woods
complete with e-re basement underneath a
new foe could be found at Grim Gables by
stepping into a summoning Circle this
ended up being a showcase for the next
crew pack skin away from all those
Halloween distractions we saw bite
descend into more Chrome madness he is
now the first person in generations to
fulfill the nothing's challenges you are
the first in generations to survive this
journey but we are seeking a warrior
will you continue the nothing want a
warrior in their enemies ranks to keep
this guy subservient the nothing grants
gifts regularly feeding his addiction oh
and I also thought we should try this
should someone who isn't bite decides to
communicate with the nothing this is
said
you're not the one we're looking for
week seven a random Star Wars week
interrupts the season but I guess
wielding a lightsaber should never be
dismissed the real progression this week
came from the herald herself we were
sent to one inhabitants on the island
some took it better than others what's
interesting is if we told Evie she's
been another sleeper agent on the island
for the peace Syndicate by talking to
her she says this so this is how it
happens I need to send a transmission
she definitely knows something it's like
she was expecting this chrome Jam
Junction was obliterated by the Chrome
but thankfully crackshot's cabin was
saved it's like the house from up and
the huge home by the maze in the north
was also elevated to safety sadly though
some pois were lost mainly the old
Coliseum near condo Canyon it's totally
gone only hexagonal pillars in its wake
and let's check on bites you feel your
identity slipping away
do not resist you will be rewarded
yep I think we lost him
week 9 the Chrome has reached far enough
to change our lobby screens in-game
tilted Towers was consumed but those
Legends at no sweat Insurance were able
to save another landmark the clock tower
week 9 saw the storyline finally return
as Jonesy and Amy got in touch it turns
out they've been working without us but
now they need our help again which is
just lap dog stuff moving moving things
around it doesn't matter though we are
close enough to hear the paradigm's next
transmission
as you know it is going to end I know
that's hard to hear but there's no
changing it now so it turns out the zero
point has fallen dormant after pleading
for help all last season that's why it
was letting out that bolt of energy
constantly Paradigm asks us to speak to
Jonesy about the loop breaker project
towards legendary Golden man Midas and
his device event a few years ago our
final task is to locate the scientists
research which is always found in the
trash well
they're here
and they spell horrible and then we send
it to the Paradigm how do we do that I
hear you ask well it's done via
bushranger who if you remember was
planted beside the reality tree last
season to spy on it from the inside and
those roots the tree have grown this
season are our way to communicate with
the Paradigm yes it's weird I agree just
don't think about it too much here's her
final message of the season
hey Amy
thanks for everything
best friend
too much too soon
just friends then got it
for some ornaments we couldn't have done
this without him without any of you and
it should be everything I need
to stay alive
oh and Rocket League cars arrived
now 10 weeks deep into the season and
the event timer finally appears counting
down the seconds to reality changing
forever the only person we need to catch
up on now is bites who over the last
seven weeks has gone on a journey like
no other he speaks to the nothing one
final time
be always Vigilant when we have need of
you you will be summoned by completing
all his quest line a huge piece of law
is revealed bite is now a warrior of the
last reality the town for games is over
the cube Queen We were certainly
defeated by flipping the entire Island
on her head is likely still alive or
maybe someone else has taken over her
Reign that war is not over
and now it's week 11 the final moments
of the season pass by the live event
happened this weekend December 3rd as we
reforge the island and stop the Chrome
The Herald the nothing the warrior of
the last reality all stand in our way
only the loop breaker protocol remains I
hope you have a good time at the event
I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see you
next time
[Music]